how nice is it to be Russian where like
if you don't like someone and you're
wealthy you can just kill them and then
everybody will look the other way yeah
it's just accepted and you don't have to
go through this whole like sneak in the
poison this would be the word
convenience convenient like because in
America like you have to sneak the
poison and like cheesecake and then
you're like watch him eat it and maybe
he doesn't take that bite and you're
just like yeah watch my figure and
you're like don't yeah get that thing in
your mouth there's ever a night to cheat
tonight is the night yeah it's a
stressful situation trying to murder
somebody that you don't like have you
thought about it no
no I'm trying to think if there's ever a
situation where I was like Ugh it could
be so much easier I never crushed your
mind never never back there one time
they're like I wish it just a light
would fall somebody interview you on a
podcast Maybe
that never happened
that never happened okay interesting
yeah I want them to live and thrive